both the artist and the neurotic are
really sensitive they both are
overwhelmed by the world
the fundamental difference is that the
neurotic is precisely the one who cannot
create he cannot Marshal a response
but the artist takes that in
and reworks it into an active work
project
so there is a kind of a feedback loop
and a circularity the artist martial a
response
there's a response that says I am here I
felt this and this matters and it is in
the ability to respond that you
experience a ton of exorcism if it frees
you from your demons
the neurotic cannot do that and so he
chokes on his intro versions
Ernest Becker really understood The
Human Condition